[? RUCHICA: ?] Hi everyone.
Welcome to the
[? G Pause ?] Talk today.
I am very glad to
present and welcome
John Osborne, who is the
National Director of Project
Welcome Home Troops.
It's a program of the non-profit
organization International
Association for Human Values.
John has been teaching
specialized courses
in human development
and leadership
to public corporates,
government,
and military professionals
for over 40 years,
a long journey in this field.
John has also spoken at the
United Nations, the World Bank,
the World Health Organization,
and many other technology
companies that we are
familiar with in the Bay
Area and outside.
He is also a speaker at Harvard
University and Wharton School.
I will hand over to John,
and let him say a few more
words about him, and walk
us through this lovely talk
on harnessing the
healing power of breath.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN OSBORNE: Thank you,
[? Ruchica, ?] and everyone
for allowing me to be here.
And I'd like to begin
today by taking you
on a slightly imaginary journey.
Imagine that here in
the United States,
there's an outbreak
of a great pandemic.
The pandemic exists
all over the world,
but there are at least 300,000
or 400,000 cases of people
coming down with this
disease, and 22 people
are dying of it every
day in the United States.
Imagine if you knew about
a pandemic like that,
it would be on the front page
of the "New York Times," right?
Well, actually, it does exist.
Pandemic has a name.
It's called Post-Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
It's affected at least
300,000 or 400,000
Americans coming back from
Afghanistan and Iraq, soldiers
and contractors and civilians.
And 22 vets a day are
committing suicide
because of the effects
of this disease.
So it's a big problem.
And I'm part of an
organization that
has one solution or one method
of dealing with this problem,
and that's what I'm going
to talk to you about today.
But first, I'd like to talk to
you a little bit about myself,
what I'm doing here,
and why I'm here.
I am a retired
venture capitalist,
and so I've been spending a
lot of time in Silicon Valley.
And also, I've been
meditating for about 45 years
and teaching different forms of
meditation and self-development
for about 40 years.
Two reasons that I'm here.
One has to do with a
person named Walter,
whom I'm happy to
tell you about.
And another has
to do with my dad.
My dad was a World War II
hero in Pacific theater,
was nominated for a Silver
Star for knocking down
48 kamikaze planes who
were trying to shoot down
his ship in 24 hours, and
always held the values
of military service
as I was growing up.
Now, you've probably
figured out from my age
that I grew up during
the Vietnam era.
And as hard as he wanted to
get me in military service,
I was running the other way.
I was not at all interested.
And it was only because
of an experience
I had with my dad late in life.
Right before he died,
I took him to see
the movie "Saving Private Ryan."
And we had about a four-hour
conversation afterwards.
And it was then
that the light went
on in my mind as to why my dad
was so interested in getting
me involved in the military.
Because for my dad,
being in the service,
as they used to
say in those days,
laid the groundwork for him
for a lifetime of service.
I grew up in a small
community in upstate New York,
and my dad organized the
volunteer ambulance corps.
And he raised money for the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial.
And later on, he joined a
human development committee
that took little old ladies to
the hospital when he had to.
So being in the military
provided him with a basis
for a lifetime of service.
And it was only at
the end of his life
that I understood
that when he wanted
to get me in the
military, it was
because he wanted me
to have those values.
So when I started getting
involved with soldiers,
I did it and continue to do
it in memory and in honor
of my dad, who passed
away shortly thereafter.
I was teaching these breathing
techniques to civilians
in, it was about 1996
in Santa Barbara,
when I got a call from
a psychologist who said,
I think I have someone who
could use some of your breathing
and meditation skills.
He said, but I'm not sure
if he's suitable for you
guys, for your course.
And when I asked
him why, he said,
because this person is
drug-addicted, he's violent,
he's suicidal, he's a danger
to himself and to others.
And oh, by the way,
he's a Vietnam vet.
And so what I did
on that course was
to give the course away so that
someone else could teach it,
and I became the buddy of this
person, whose name was Walter.
And he had a little
bit of a difficult time
with the meditation and
the yoga and the breathing,
but he got through the course.
And I saw that it had
transformed him a lot.
And I lost touch with Walter
until about five years later.
I was doing a
meet-and-greet kind
of a reception in Los Angeles.
And there was a
long line of people
that were coming up
to say hello to me.
And all of a sudden,
I saw this person.
He was about 6' 6" in a suit.
And I vaguely recognized him.
And he came up and
he gave me a hug
and lifted me off the ground.
And I'm like, who
is this person?
And he said, John,
he said, I'm Walter.
And Walter, by that
time, was the head
of data processing services for
the county of Santa Barbara.
He owned a car.
He had a girlfriend.
He had an apartment.
He was off his drugs, and
he was leading a happy life.
Now, I'm not sure what
the complete connection
between the course
that I took with Walter
and his present state.
But it planted a seed in me.
I thought, wow, for people
who are in such anguish,
having such trouble being
in the present moment,
this might be something
that would be useful.
So about eight years
ago, I was asked again
by a colleague to
join them in doing
a brief introduction
at a Vet Center.
For those of you who
are not very familiar
with the military, since the
Vietnam War and people coming
back having so much trouble
transiting to civilian life,
the VA has set up these
neighborhood Vet Centers
where vets can come
and talk to each other,
maybe get some help with
their processing of papers,
and join a group,
and meet other vets,
and deal with their problems.
And I taught some just
initial breathing techniques
to some of these vets, and the
results were so transformative.
These are people that
were running red lights
in Santa Monica, California,
because they were afraid
that there was an IED
at the side of the road.
How many people are
familiar with PTS,
some of the symptoms of PTS?
Some of them are
memories which crowd out
the real estate inside them
to the point where they can't
be in the present moment,
emotional numbness,
having trouble with extremes
in emotions, especially
anger, suicidal thoughts,
depression, sleeplessness,
and for a lot of them, a
tendency to self-medicate,
either with drugs or alcohol.
These are people
that have either
seen something or lost
someone or done something
that they regret
hugely, and come back.
And the problem with PTS is
that it doesn't go away just
by itself.
I've treated a lot of vets that
were even in the Vietnam War.
40 years later, they're
still having problems.
I'll tell you more about
this in a little bit,
but I thought you'd like to
meet some of my students.
So we're going to start by
seeing a short video with some
of their experiences, and then
we'll talk a little bit more
about what I do.
OK?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TRAVIS: When I was a freshman
in high school, 9/11 happened.
And I think that kind of planted
the seed for my eventual going
into the military.
DON: My name is Don Rodriguez.
I was born and raised
in Brooklyn, New York.
I went into the
military in 1985.
ROGER: You can't walk through
that amount of bloodshed
and bodies and black
bags and-- you just
can't walk through that
and not be affected by it.
KYLE: We spent 16
months on the ground.
We were actually the longest
unit to serve in Iraq.
And then I deployed
to Iraq again
in 2009 for another nine months.
LOUIS: You know,
you have to kind
of detach from your humanity
to do that over there.
And then you come back,
and you have a hard time
reattaching to
normal civilian life.
ROGER: You could see somebody
die in the sidewalk in front
of you and step right over
them and keep on going.
They're not personal to me.
JIM: I think the
death and the dying
that I saw there grabbed
a hold of me daily.
We were getting mortared daily.
LOREN: I realized within
a few weeks of being there
that the odds of any of
us living through a year
there didn't feel
very good at all.
TRAVIS: On the
second deployment,
there was a rocket attack on
my base that killed three guys
and injured another one.
ANTHONY: When the next
generation of roadside bombs,
the EFP came in,
I was terrified,
because they would go
right through our armor.
But even when you're
on base, I mean,
they're firing rockets in.
They fire mortars in.
REMO: We had been there
less than 30 days,
and we lost one helicopter
with everybody onboard.
It was shot down.
DON: Well, I came back
injured, came back blind.
I really had no support
of any family or anything.
I felt alone, isolated.
TRAVIS: For me, when I got
back, life was the same.
For my girlfriend at
the time, apparently, I
was very different,
very-- totally changed.
And she would tell me this,
and I never understood it.
REMO: I know I lost
something, but I'm not
really quite sure what
it was that I lost.
RICH: I had changed enough
and didn't recognize
it enough that it actually put
a lot of strain on my marriage
and was one of the
factors that led up
to what turned into a divorce.
NATHAN: My fiancee and I
started having some trouble.
And I was drinking a lot.
LOUIS: I had bad dreams,
panic attacks, anger.
I had a lot of anger.
ROGER: The anger
that was there--
anger became my best friend.
And if I wasn't angry
about something,
I was looking for something
to get angry about.
EILEEN: Roger was never abusive,
but I was afraid of his anger.
You start just not knowing what
it's going to be like one day
to the next.
STEPHEN: She didn't know
when I would get angry,
what I would get angry about.
And it would happen
so quickly that she
wasn't prepared for it.
ANTHONY: There is
no graduated scale.
It's 0 to 10, that's it.
LOREN: Something unknown would
flare up something in me,
and I would lose track of
what was going on around me.
GREG: I lived on
antidepressants,
which I have lived on
for the last four years.
I've been on every one that's
probably been available.
JIM: The life, as
I saw it inside,
if I have to continue life this
way, it's not worth living.
DON: I felt lost.
I attempted suicide twice.
Substance abuse.
Just anything that
would ease the pain.
NATHAN: I white-knuckled
it for about nine months,
and then it just--
the nightmares
and the flashbacks, all
that stuff just finally
overwhelmed me.
DON: They tried putting me
through prolonged exposure,
cognitive processing
therapy, all
the other different therapies
that they could possibly
think of.
And it helped a little bit
more, but I was still in a hole.
JOHN OSBORNE: If it's not too
personal a question to ask you,
can you describe what it
felt like being in that hole?
DON: Like being in hell.
Whatever the worst
thing you could possibly
imagine about hell,
that's where I was at.
JOHN OSBORNE: I
think that there's
been combat trauma and
Post-Traumatic Stress syndrome
as long as men and women
have been fighting wars.
Project Welcome Home Troops
started in Southern California
about seven years ago,
answering a need for some vets
at a Vet Center who wanted to
learn more about breathing,
stress management,
meditation in an effort
to help them manage their
combat trauma symptoms
and Post-Traumatic
Stress syndrome.
ROGER: The first time I took
the course in Fort Worth, Texas
was 10 months ago.
JIM: I had no idea
what to expect.
And as we got into the program
and started to do the exercises
and do the breathing
and so on, I thought,
eh, this might be all right.
This might help.
LOUIS: At first, I thought
it was a little bit hokey,
you know, first coming in.
STEPHEN: The more
we got into it,
the more it stopped being just
a bunch of hippie nonsense.
It started dislodging
certain internal barriers
I guess I had built up.
TRAVIS: I think also by,
like, day two or three,
you started building that
camaraderie between the people
within the group,
which was nice.
JIM: The end session
there where we
did the power breathing
was the ultimate.
I thought, wow.
I was just so relaxed.
TRAVIS: You know, right away,
with the breathing exercises,
it taught me how to relax.
GREG: It's almost like you have
to get way deep down in there
with all of that deep breathing.
And then it just
seems to take it all,
and you exhale it all out.
ROGER: My son stopped over, and
we were shooting the breeze.
And he's a pretty direct kid.
He says, hey, Pop, the VA got
you on some new drugs or what?
[LAUGHS] So I thought,
you know, it's not just
me that notices it.
RICH: When I
finished the course,
I didn't notice the
changes immediately.
Everyone around me did.
ANTHONY: I felt like
I did before I ever
want to Iraq the first time.
RICH: It's surreal to have
someone come up to you
and say something like, why
are you happy all the time?
You're smiling again.
Did something change?
STEPHEN: I am a
different person now.
Just night and day.
RICH: You know, you're really--
it's like you're you again
from three or four
or five years ago.
NATHAN: My ex, she said, I
really like this new guy.
You remind me of the guy
that I had met years ago.
LOUIS: So I can focus
and concentrate better
when I'm at school.
And I can be around
other people.
STEPHEN: My mood goes like
this as opposed to spikes.
JOHN OSBORNE: The
particular techniques
that we teach are very
effective and very
popular with
veterans-- number one,
because they like
learning something
that they can do on their own.
They're very self-reliant,
independent people.
Number two, it's preferable
to a lot of people
to other treatments,
like psychiatric drugs
or long-term psychotherapy.
And number three,
it's highly effective.
And they like doing it in
a class with other vets.
They bond with other vets.
They do the program
ongoing with other vets.
And many of them now are
out finding other vets
that need to take the program.
DON: I don't know.
The breathing just
opened up something in me
where I could just feel
better about myself.
And I realized that there were
some things I may have done,
but that I had to do
in order to survive,
in order to be here today.
If not, I wouldn't be here.
STEPHEN: Just on a
completely practical level,
I sleep at night, and I don't
have to take a handful of meds
to do it.
ROGER: I am not taking any
medication for anxiety.
I'm not taking any sleep aids.
I'm not taking any meds.
And that is not a giant
step, that's a giant leap.
TRAVIS: Now I'm a teacher
for Project Welcome Home
Troops, which is great.
Sharing this information, these
techniques, and the knowledge,
seeing the change
in people, I think,
is the biggest driving force.
GREG: About a week before
I came on this course,
I was in the hospital
for five days.
Major depression.
Really didn't give a damn
if I lived, you know?
I really think that
I have improved
about 75% in just
the last two months.
ROGER: I'm going
to keep doing it.
I don't know how it works,
I don't know why it works,
but it works for me.
GREG: And that's where this
program really probably helped
me more than anything is it
kind of gave me myself back,
you know?
DON: At the path that
I was going prior
to having done the exercise
with you guys, I don't think I
would have made it 10, 20 years.
So when you're asking me now
20, 30 years down the line,
I am looking at it as
a present, something
that's just a gift
that's been given to me,
maybe one more chance
to get things right.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOHN OSBORNE: So this
Power Breath workshop
is a five-day workshop
that we offer for vets.
It's a combination
of yoga, meditation,
and a very specialized
form of rhythmic breathing
called the Sudarshan
Kriya yoga technique.
Most people at Google
know that breathing
is one of the main
sources of energy, right?
You can live for several weeks
without food, several days
without water, but you
can't live for very long
without breath.
So breath is, we all know,
a major source of energy.
It's also a major
part of our health.
About 80% of the toxins
that leave the body
leave the body
through the breath.
But there's a third
mysterious aspect
to the breath that allows this
workshop to be very powerful.
And that is that the breath
is a very powerful link
between the mind and the
body and the emotions.
How many people have
been at a meeting
at Google where you
know that somebody's not
having a very good day
or not having a very
good time at the meeting,
because you look over,
and they're like--
[BREATHES VERY DEEPLY].
And you think, in
about five seconds,
I don't want to be in
this meeting anymore.
How many people have had an
experience in or out of Google
like that?
When you see that, emotions
change and the breath changes.
We see it often backwards.
We see the breath
change and we think, OK,
there's an emotional change.
Any mothers here
with small children?
Anybody?
Right.
And so have you ever sung
a lullaby to your child,
and you see the breath getting
slower and getting longer,
and you're thinking,
in 30 more seconds,
my child is finally
going to sleep?
So there's this important link.
And it's that link that we use
in the Power Breath workshop.
Because most of the time, we
notice the emotional change,
and then we notice the change
in the rhythm of the breath.
But we teach specific
rhythms of the breath
to the vets, which allow them
to come to a center place
no matter what else is
going on in their life,
and to come back in
the present moment.
These are people
that are trapped
in their memories and their
physiological reactions
to the past.
I said at the
beginning, these are
people that run red
lights in Los Angeles,
because they're afraid there's
a bomb at the side of the road.
They're not able to live
in the present at all.
Most of us, our mind swings
from the past to the future,
and sometimes lives in
the present, hopefully.
But for them, their mind
is trapped in the past.
And these rhythmic breaths, the
[? Sky ?] Sudarshan Kriya yoga
breath work not only
brings them to the present
but allows the body
naturally to begin
to let go of trauma and
stress-- not just in that day,
but on a permanent basis.
And they refer to some research.
There's just been one pilot
study done on this program.
It was done at the Center for
the Study of the Healthy Mind,
Dr. Richard Davidson--
some of you may know him.
I think he's actually
come and spoken
at Google-- at the
University of Wisconsin.
And that research showed,
with a control group
of 10 vets taking the course and
10 vets doing something else,
over a period of seven
days, that their symptoms
of Post-Traumatic Stress lowered
on an average of 40% to 50%.
That's interesting.
But what is also interesting
is that when they measured them
six months later, the
symptoms were still lower.
And when they measured
them a year later,
the symptoms were still lower.
Now, it's still too early to
know what that pilot means.
But it means generally
that their experience
of their own trauma,
the sleeplessness,
the hyper-arousal,
the flash to anger
was lessened during the course.
And whether or not they
practiced these techniques
afterwards, that
level of symptom
was still lower after six
months and after a year.
So now, eight years later,
we've taught about 1,000 vets.
And we are training teachers
as fast as we can, because,
as I said earlier, there's
300,000 to 400,000 people
walking around with
Post-Traumatic Stress
from these wars.
And a lot of them don't want to
be on drugs, because the drugs
have a lot of side effects,
and they mask the symptoms,
but they don't really
cure the cause.
And they don't want
to go-- especially
if they're still in the
service for-- there's
a great stigma for going
for psychiatric care.
So programs like these
provide an alternate way
of dealing with the
Post-Traumatic Stress.
And as I said earlier,
it's something
that they can do by
themselves for themselves.
So it's a program that
the soldiers like a lot.
I thought I'd teach you
maybe one of the very
preliminary forms of
breathing, if you'd
like to have that demonstrated.
I was just at the
Aspen Brain Forum,
and I thought I had made
it safely off the stage,
and I was just ready to step off
the stage, and somebody said,
can you show us one of
the forms of breathing
that the soldiers do?
So this is a form of yogic
breathing called Bhastrika.
How many people would like
to learn just a little bit
about it?
OK.
So sit back in your
chairs a little bit.
Sit up.
And we're going to breathe
in and out through the nose.
This is a form of breathing
that will give you
a little bit of energy.
In Southern California, it's
nicknamed the Starbucks breath.
So we're going to put our
hands in baby fists like this.
Yeah?
And we're going to
breathe in, and we're
going to allow
our hands to go up
into what I call the
Glory Hallelujah pose.
And then we're going to
grasp an imaginary bar
and breathe out through
the nose sharply.
Come down.
Breathe in and go up.
Exhale, come down.
And we'll do it in rhythm, and
we'll do maybe 10 repetitions.
Should we do that?
OK.
Take a normal breath in and out.
Let's see if we can
do this together.
Ready, begin.
In, out, in, out, in, out.
And put a little energy into it.
And relax.
Close your eyes.
Take a transition breath
in through the nose.
And out.
And just close your eyes and
see if you feel somewhere
inside a little bit more energy
than you had 10 minutes ago.
Open the eyes.
You can even do
this at your cubicle
if nobody thinks
you're looking too
strange in the middle
of the afternoon.
Instead of going to
get a cup of coffee,
you can do maybe
three sets of 15 to 20
of these with a little
bit of rest in between.
Not something you'd like to
go home and do for 45 minutes
while you're watching
TV, you know.
Three sets of maybe 10 to 15.
I thought maybe, too,
you'd like to experience
a kind of guided meditation
that we do with the vets.
Would you like to do that?
OK.
We'll do this for
maybe 10 to 15 minutes,
and then I'll be around to
answer any questions that you
have about the program.
So anyone who came in late,
if you'd have your cell phones
turned to vibrate,
that would be great.
Can everybody see me OK?
So all you have to do with
this guided meditation is close
your eyes and
follow instructions.
Let's sit comfortably with
both our feet on the floor,
spine straight, palms up
on the lap, eyes closed.
Let's begin by taking a normal
breath in through the nose.
And out.
Begin by finding ourselves
in this environment,
listening to all the noises
around us-- conversations
from the other room, the hum
of the electrical system.
And feel that connection
between our body and the chair
we're sitting on.
Now perhaps you're feeling
a little bit more in harmony
with your environment.
Become aware of
your physical body.
It may be feeling tired.
It may be feeling rested.
It may be feeling
a little agitated.
There could be some
aches or pains or twinges
in certain parts of the body.
Just be with your body
just as it is right now.
Innocently, put your
awareness on your right foot.
Right knee.
Right thigh and hip.
Left foot.
Left knee.
Left thigh and hip.
Stomach.
Abdomen.
Chest.
Right arm.
And shoulder.
Left arm.
Face.
Between the eyebrows.
Top of the head.
Whole body.
Allow your awareness
to flow like a river
through your whole body.
The top of your head to
the soles of your feet.
Through your whole body.
Become aware of your thoughts.
Positive thoughts,
negative thoughts,
it doesn't much matter.
Just watch them flow by
like they're in a river,
and don't try to control them
or judge them in any way.
Underneath our thoughts,
we all have feelings.
Allow yourself to become
aware of your feelings.
Happy feelings, sad
feelings, anxious feelings,
angry feelings,
peaceful feelings.
Whatever kind of feelings
are there, just observe them.
Underneath the bodily
sensations and the thoughts
and the feelings, there's a
deeper place within each of us.
Deep and silent like an ocean.
Allow yourself to drop into
that deeper, silent place.
In that deep, silent
place, there's
a well of peace and joy.
Once again, put your
awareness on your feelings.
Become aware of your thoughts.
Become aware of
your physical body.
Take a breath in.
And let go.
Begin to become aware of the
environment in which you find
yourselves.
Feel once again the contact
of your body with the seat
that you're sitting on.
Take another deep breath in.
And let go.
Begin to stretch a little.
You can wiggle your
fingers and your toes.
Move in your chair a little bit.
And taking your own time,
as much time as you need,
you can slowly and
gradually open your eyes.
It was good?
Great.
I forgot to ask if there
are any vets present.
Anyone here?
So whenever I see
a vet in uniform
at an airport or anywhere else,
I always take the opportunity--
although, it always embarrasses
them-- to say thank you
for your service to our country.
I was talking to someone who
was born in a foreign country,
and they were trying to
decide whether they wanted
to contribute and
support our organization.
And they said, well, you know,
I give to my home country.
I give lots of things
to my home country.
And I said, well, while
you're here in Silicon Valley,
it's not your home country
that's protecting you,
it's the American
servicemen and women
who have risked their lives.
And coming back,
they're the people
that can really use our help.
They've stuck their
necks out for us,
risked their lives for us.
And it's now time for us
to be able to help them
in whatever way we can.
I want to tell you just one
or two more stories from-- one
came up for me during
meditation about the vets
that I've been lucky enough to
work with, and then to tell you
why I'm here at Google today.
I had a Vietnam vet.
He wasn't in this film,
but he was a dog handler
in Vietnam, which meant that he
had a dog that he worked with.
And they'd send the dogs
into the Viet Cong tunnels,
and they'd come
out the other end.
And one day, he sent
his dog into a tunnel,
and a whole bunch of
Viet Cong came out
the other end of the tunnel, and
they started shooting at him.
He wasn't really a combatant,
but he had a weapon,
and he shot back.
And when they did
the body count,
he had a special
weapon, so he knew
who had been killed by other
people and who he had killed.
And one of the
people he had killed,
unfortunately, was a
13-year-old Vietnamese girl.
And on the last day of
this five-day course,
he came up to me and he
grabbed me and he shook me,
this guy did.
He was about 70 years old.
And he said, she's
gone, she's gone.
And I'm like, who's gone?
And he said, that girl
I killed, he said, she's
been in my dreams every
night for the last 40 years.
And last night was the first
night I slept through the night
and she didn't come
back in my dreams.
So imagine what it would be
like to live a life like that,
and then to live a life
free of that kind of thing.
Another Vietnam vet I taught,
when he did this breathing
for the first time, he
experienced a memory
that he had repressed
ever since Vietnam.
He had forgotten
completely about it
where a hand grenade had
come down in a foxhole
that he was in, and he had
thrown the hand grenade up
in the air, and saved
himself and his comrades
in the process.
And it exploded about
30 feet above his head.
And he said, during
the breathing,
not only did he smell the
sulfur of the grenade--
I think that's sort of
an interesting fact.
He said, but there was
a whole part of his mind
that had been trapped behind
this repressed memory, he said,
that started to come
out during the course.
He had access to it for
the first time in 40 years.
And he got actually a little
angry at the instructors.
He said, where were
you 40 years ago?
He said, my whole
life would have
been different had I had
access to this particular part
of my mind.
So there's a lot of people
out there waiting for us.
And a lot of people in
American corporations,
especially in Silicon Valley,
are taking an interest in vets.
I spoke to Vets
Network at Cisco.
I don't know if there's a
Vets Network here at Google.
But I spoke to one, and they're
reaching out to other vets
to help other vets.
And when I was at
Microsoft, they
sponsored a course in Seattle.
So maybe there's some
people in this audience
that would like to help.
We're a volunteer-based
organization.
We don't charge the
vets for what we do,
but that means we rely on
lots of different volunteers
for lots of different things.
So if anybody here
thinks that they'd
like to get involved and
help vets, as I said,
there are 300,000
or 400,000 vets out
there who need our help.
And I can use the
brain power at Google,
I'm sure, to figure out new
ways to help reach out to them.
I thought I'd just
save 5 or 10 minutes
to see if anybody
has any questions.
And there's no question that's
impolite or too direct to ask.
I'd be really
grateful if somebody
had a couple of
questions that they
want to ask me
about the program.
Yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: Mic please.
AUDIENCE: So at
Google, we always
think about scaling things.
And I'm just wondering,
have you tried
to get this into the
out-processing process
within the military
organizations themselves?
JOHN OSBORNE: We have.
And there's some people
at very high levels.
I mean, the head of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff
has seen our program
and is acting about it.
But if you've been
in the military,
you know things don't happen
necessarily at breakneck speed.
So yeah.
Some people at very high
levels are aware of us
and are watching us.
It could be a little
while before they--
but in the VA, the Veterans
Administration for people
who have been released
from the military,
there are different
layers of treatment
that are like the
layers of an onion.
And the outermost
one of these is
the neighborhood Vet Centers,
which you may be familiar with.
And slowly but surely,
people at these Vet Centers
are sponsoring courses
and sending their people
to our courses.
And that's our way into the VA,
because then the VA hospitals
want to do research on us,
and then it goes straight up.
But it could take
a little while.
That's all right.
I have a little time.
And I never thought when
we taught our first course
that we would have
taught 1,000 vets by now.
But there's 1,000 down
and 300,000 to go,
so we have a ways to go.
Scalability, there's
several factors.
I know you're great at
analysis here in Google.
One is training teachers
who are good at working
with this population.
Vets come in not trusting
very many people.
They don't trust the government.
They don't trust the military.
They have a really hard time
relating to civilian life,
because their values and
experiences are so different.
So you need to find teachers
that can-- especially vets.
And we're training
vets to be teachers now
who can reach out
and relate to vets.
So it takes a certain amount
of skill to teach teachers.
And also, obviously,
finances are a factor,
because we have to not
only train teachers
but have them travel
around to where vets are.
And access to government
resources and government
places.
I had somebody call me--
it broke my heart-- who
was in the middle of a PTSD
residency program in a VA
hospital, and we couldn't
get in to teach him.
He was like, I need your help.
Please come and help me.
But we couldn't get access
to that particular part
of the program.
So government access,
funds, and the ability
to train many more teachers.
I think that the
vets that we teach
will become the inheritors
of this program.
I think it will eventually
be vet-run by people
who graduated from the program.
And I'm really
working as hard as I
can to make sure that
happens as soon as possible.
AUDIENCE: The thousand you've
been able to touch and teach,
is it regional or global?
JOHN OSBORNE: It's
interesting you say that,
because it started out
just in the United States.
But someone made a documentary
film of us in Europe.
It was actually about the
work of Richard Davidson, who
did our research, but it
included one of our workshops.
And so now we're teaching all
over Europe, and especially
in Eastern Europe and
Sarajevo and places like that
where there's a lot of PTS.
And we just trained our first
two teachers in Australia.
It's also been taught in Russia.
It's also been taught
in-- it's beginning
to be taught in South
America as well.
So it's beginning to be global.
But right now, it's strongest
in the United States.
We're the ones who have the
most veterans coming back
from the latest wars.
AUDIENCE: So yes, also, thank
you very much for what you do.
So my stepbrother was in Iraq.
And I know for a fact
that he suffers from it.
He hasn't been diagnosed with
PTSD, but he was a medic.
And I don't know how to--
I believe in my heart
this would help him, but I
don't know how to approach it.
And I was wondering if you
could speak of-- because there
was themes in the
film of the vets
who had taken the
program of seeing it
as hokey and kind of-- it's
a lot of times associated
with pseudoscience, in a way.
And how do you introduce
it to vets that are--
where this is a
completely new thing and--
JOHN OSBORNE: And
they're skeptical.
Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN OSBORNE: First is that
they can go to the website.
They can see this
film for themselves.
And secondly, we can put them,
if they write into the website,
in touch with a vet
who's taken the course.
And there's something
about vets talking
to vets which has
instant credibility.
This fellow Roger,
the one who said,
I don't know how it works,
I don't know why it works,
we sent him around.
And he just went to a
Vets Center in Texas
and sat in to a vets
support group, and said,
my name's Roger,
I'm a Vietnam vet,
I used to be on 20
different medications,
I'm not on any
medications anymore.
And they're like,
where do I sign up?
So vets have a lot
of credibility.
And if we can put him
in touch with one who's
taken the course,
they trust each other.
They don't trust very
much else in life,
but they trust each other.
So either the website.
Or I have business cards if you
want to get in touch with me,
I'll put him in direct
touch with a vet.
But there has to be at least
a little interest on his part.
Just if you tell them they can
get off their drugs-- what they
don't tell you
about these drugs is
that they have
many side effects.
Some people have been on
them for 30 or 40 years.
And one of them is
sexual dysfunction.
They don't talk about it much,
but if you can get them off--
you know, if they think
they can get off those drugs
and have a life again,
it's pretty motivating.
AUDIENCE: You
thought that it was
a wonderful way of
servicing people who
were returning from war.
How did you get into meditation?
JOHN OSBORNE: Way back when?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN OSBORNE: I was teaching a
program called Outward Bound.
Some of you may know
about Outward Bound.
But it's a program of take
people out in the wilderness
and develop skills, you know,
self-confidence, and things.
And I was teaching kids
from the inner city,
and it was a really
high-stress situation.
And we didn't have any time off,
and the kids were demanding,
and you're pretty exhausted
all the time in a wilderness
environment keeping them safe.
And I noticed that
one of my colleagues
had more energy than I did.
His sense of humor
was indestructible.
He gave more to the kids.
He got more back.
And so it being the '60s, I
took him aside and asked him
what drug he was on, you
know, what he was doing.
And he said, it's this
thing that I do twice a day
for 20 minutes, this meditation.
And I said, that
sounds really weird.
And if it sounds weird in 2010,
it sounded much stranger back
in the late-60s.
And then he did
something for which
I'll be forever
grateful, because he
was a really good friend.
He put his arm on my shoulder.
He says, I know it sounds weird.
He said, but for my sake,
he said, check it out.
And that was in the
summer before my freshman
year in college.
Luckily, I found a meditation
instructor that year,
my freshman year in college, and
I started because of my friend.
And that's how I started,
and it went on from there.
AUDIENCE: The
courses you mentioned
are really for the [INAUDIBLE].
What about for the civilians?
Like, I'm really
interested in starting
on the path of meditation.
I agree that in the 15
minutes, I am more calmer.
When I stepped into this
room, I was very anxious
about a lot of things.
I am way more calmer, and
I feel that, you know,
I have certain solutions
to my issues now.
So I'm really wondering, how
can I get introduced to it
and kind of pursue it?
JOHN OSBORNE: There's
many kinds of meditation.
I understand you already have
meditation and mindfulness
being taught here.
This breathing meditation
is an especially powerful
introductory version of
meditation or introduction
to meditation.
For people like
the vets, something
as subtle as mindfulness
is beyond their grasp.
But the breathing
meditation brings you
to a very, very deep
place very quickly.
And you're lucky that you have
some people in Google that
actually teach that
form of meditation.
One of them's right
over there, Mark Ball.
He's one of my-- I respect
Mark's teaching more than many,
many other people that I know.
You're very lucky to
have him at Google.
And I believe he offers courses
in this breathing meditation.
Is that right?
MARK BALL: Yes.
JOHN OSBORNE: Periodically.
So see Mark if
you're interested.
We do teach civilians.
I teach a program that
teaches in corporations.
I've taught at Harvard
Business School and Wharton.
And a lot of people
are understanding now
that the greatest resource that
any company like Google has
is the resource that's in here.
And we don't always have
full access to that, right?
You didn't have full
access to that resource
when you walked in here today,
right, because of your anxiety
and whatever.
So whatever a company can do
to maximize people's access
to that resource
is going to show up
in many, many ways for the
benefit of the company.
So when I'm not teaching
vets, sometimes I
teach people in
corporate environments
around the country.
Once again, I'd like
to thank [? Ruchica ?]
and her colleagues and everybody
at Google for having me
here today.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]